I want to say you know this whole week
you know I'd be lost in my problems
stressed out and then in an instant all
of that can go away and your priorities
really shift and today all of my little
problems that I thought were big is the
world we're gone and I realized that
there's people hurting right now and you
guys create beautiful music thank you so
much for lifting me up let's continue to
reach out hold each other down and lift
each other up thank you so much the
Grammy
what the hell ha what how is this moment
um let me come back to it I'm above this
moment I'm floating all over the place
right now
I can't tell you I'll tell you tomorrow
I feel really humbled and honored and
I'm shocked what would you tell that
girl who was struggling and trying to
find her way a few years ago and what
would you tell her about this moment
being on the Grammy stage she wouldn't
believe me but she would believe in
herself and that's all that matters and
where did what happen when you drop it
[Music]